hey man it's me Kevin Smith
today we are talking about each and
every Jedi and Sith
Star Wars saga movies and TV shows
encapsulate an abundance of Epic
American storytelling this is our
mythology kids we didn't come up with
the Greek gods of the Roman gods I think
the Greeks and the Romans came up with
them but Star Wars George Lucas America
this is ours we're not touching the
extended Universe Cannon there's way too
much of that so we're going to start off
with Qui-Gon Jinn game he only joined
the franchise about two decades ago this
franchise been happening since I think
1642. it's one of the oldest movie
franchises in the world George Lucas
went back and made the prequels man so
he introduced the ultimate Jedi Qui-Gon
Jinn who from the moment we see them in
The Phantom Menace him and a young Ben
Kenobi oh they're badasses
the Jedis have turned into superheroes
for heaven's sakes man they take long
jumps they run real fast they could
block many shots with a lightsaber it's
incredible the presentation that we get
of a Jedi thanks to Liam Neeson's quiet
no damn good with a lightsaber though
got himself killed pretty easily I mean
he good with it don't get me wrong but
like Darth Maul much better next up
Anakin Skywalker we'd heard the name of
Anakin Skywalker you know in the Return
of the Jedi cease to be Anakin Skywalker
and became Darth Vader and then in
Return of the Jedi we saw the face of
Anakin Skywalker and in that trilogy
that was uh poetic very poignant then
when George Lucas went back into the
prequels he was like you know what the
story is the story is about the little
boy who becomes Darth Vader we watch him
go from a hopeful little boy full of
love for his mom to a Tuscan Raider
killing psychopath you know you look at
that movie where you know he comes back
and he's talking about like I went out
there and I killed them all
and not just the men and you were like
that's a little dark well hold my beer
because later on thanks to order 66
Anakin Skywalker is going to cut
children down with a lightsaber
something that I honestly thought they
were going to correct in Obi-Wan Kenobi
I thought they were going to reveal that
he didn't really kill those kids he just
had them all come over the dark side
because why would you have your main
character be that [ __ ] evil he's a
broken little kid but unlike Batman
who's also a broken little kid who's
like I'm going to do the right thing
this son of a [ __ ] holy [ __ ] did
nothing right until the very [ __ ] end
now you can have a whole last
conversation about Anakin Skywalker and
not even Touch the Hem of the cape
next up the man himself Darth Vader
hands down the greatest cinematic bad
guy in movie history where are those
Transmissions
the appearance alone is visually
captivating not just for a child for
adults as well but for a kid like we
didn't know if he was a robot or not
like there was no internet so you
couldn't be like is Darth Vader a robot
or a human being
everyone always hopes there's a little
piece of Anakin Skywalker left inside
Darth Vader and you know his son is the
one that gotta get so emotional talking
about should make pretend [ __ ] his son's
the one that was able to kind of deliver
him that's beautiful
next up Yoda the king of the Jedi oh we
all love Yoda you know Star Wars was a
massive hit Empire comes out they're
like we gotta show him something new and
they gave him Yoda a muppet for heaven's
sakes man came right from Jim Henson's
Creature shot voiced by the great Frank
Oz himself this character captures the
imagination because he don't look like
us every other character who's a Jedi
you look at and you can compare yourself
to this is a magical creature we don't
even know what Yoda's race species is we
just know that boy oh boy he controls
the force like a big bad way and he's so
tiny he's so he's trial size he's fun
style and still he can be that tiny and
have that much power next up Count Dooku
played by the great Christopher Lee one
of the greatest lightsaber battles in
the history of all the Star Wars movies
never gets enough credit everyone always
goes for Qui-Gon and Obi-Wan Kenobi and
Darth Maul for The Duel of the Fates and
[ __ ] but Yoda pop it around the room and
beating the [ __ ] out of Count Dooku
especially when he comes out and he's
like
absolute Bliss next up Darth Sidious
look what you have made we're the
Emperor as we've always known him boy
this guy he just sticks around man he's
a gum on a shoe even when they kill him
they threw him off the Darth Vader kills
him and return to the Jedi
[Music]
you know he's responsible for all this
ultimately Anakin Skywalker makes his
own choices but this guy is like you
know the the dark Jiminy Cricket on his
shoulder being like you know it's better
if we [ __ ] have all the power don't
hide don't beat a phantom menace be the
menace menace Be a Menace to Society if
you will next up we got Obi-Wan Kenobi
and we get to split them into two
there's old Ben Kenobi portrayed by the
great Alec Guinness I was once a Jedi
Knight the same as your father and then
of course we have Ewan McGregor who
played Obi-Wan Kenobi in the prequels
and now he's playing him in the
Fantastic Obi-Wan Kenobi series on
Disney plus hello there give it up for
Alec Guinness for heaven's sakes he's
your Jedi Grandpa everybody knows him
he's familiar not much of a lightsaber
fighter as we saw from that final battle
with him and Darth Vader
but young Ben Kenobi young Obi-Wan oh
just watch him fight
look at him kill Darth Maul in the
prequels look at him fight Anakin
Skywalker again in the Obi-Wan Kenobi
series next up Mace Windu
hands down the coolest Jedi on the
planet got a purple lightsaber what more
you need to say about it for heaven's
sakes this is Samuel L Jackson they
really should have just named the
character Samuel L Jackson
next up Luke Scotland
oh look this is the only Skywalker you
should ever give a [ __ ] about
Skywalker the original hero this is the
one that George Lucas carved from the
writings of Joseph Campbell the the
Mythic hero he's a nobody he's a zero
from a farm Planet [ __ ] nobody knows
this guy he got no specific powers and
stuff he whines about power converters
when I was going into Toshi station to
pick up some power converters and
somehow the fate of the Galaxy depends
on him by the end of this movie I know
exactly what my favorite Luke Skywalker
moment is and it belongs most recently
to the Mandalorian
Luke Skywalker shows up and he does
everything that you ever wanted him to
do
he is the Jedi that you dreamed he would
become by the end of Return of the Jedi
takes people out left and right just no
problem whatsoever it is absolute Bliss
we were given the version of Luke
Skywalker that we always hoped that we
would see hats off to Dave filoni and
John Favreau for finally bringing him to
that place and boom he gets there he is
a Jedi master
next upington
uh I know on the internet there's some
people that maintain that Jar Jar Binks
is a Sith Lord I disagree
I think Jar Jar Binks though is a
character that could easily be redeemed
now mind you we don't have to be
redeemed for everybody all you got to do
is make this dude a badass killer in a
TV show just give him Misa kills
next up Ahsoka Tano
who is a character who came from the
Animated Series uh as a character I
absolutely love not just because now
she's being played by Rosario Dawson she
was the Padawan if you will to Anakin
Skywalker so just as Anakin Skywalker
was a Padawan to Ben Kenobi Ben Kenobi
was a Padawan to Qui-Gon Ahsoka was a
Padawan to Anakin Skywalker and so she
was tight with him while he was still on
against Skywalker and then of course we
know eventually he becomes Darth Vader
and so their friendship their bond
completely splits and there's an amazing
episode of rebels where Ahsoka
encounters Anakin as Darth Vader for the
first time she hasn't seen Anakin in
years and it is incredibly powerful it
is emotional as hell because she's
fighting like her best friend almost a
father figure panic in the Skywalker
wasn't weak I destroyed him
I will avenge his death at one point she
gets the upper hand and she [ __ ]
slices his [ __ ] mask and you see
Anakin they just kind of repeated it on
Obi-Wan Kenobi and you see Anakin
underneath and he looks at her and he
says
and she melts and she's like and then he
comes back as Vader and just goes back
at him Ahsoka was the one that took him
as far as she could to get to a Luke
Skywalker moment where his son could
redeem him I don't think you get that
Luke Skywalker Redemption of Anakin
Skywalker without Ahsoka Tano in the
process yes being an Awakening next up
supreme leader snoke
this character was a mystery for most of
the sequels like some people were online
were like that's Mace Windu you're gonna
find out that was Mace Windu after you
got pitched out the window by the
emperor he got saved and they turned him
into emperor snoke not true for Phil
yeah Destiny the great Andy Circus
portrayed him and Andy Circus takes that
motion capture stuff very seriously
it's unexpected you know because you're
like well that's the big bad we're gonna
deal with him for all three holy [ __ ]
but we found out he was cloned and [ __ ]
like that next up
let me tell you every moment of grogu in
the Mandalorian is absolute Magic
good job there has been no false moves
with that character there's been no
moment where like grogu wouldn't do that
Pitch Perfect character development
something to be said for having a
character that doesn't speak something
I've always believed in next up Darth
Maul
one of the single best looking
characters in Star Wars movie and one of
the single biggest losers in all of Star
Wars one movie he gets where he's badass
and he's he's probably the best
lightsaber fighter we've ever seen
[Applause]
Ray Park who played Darth Maul do all
sorts of flips and kicks you got this
incredible display look at the power of
this Sith and then he just gets [ __ ]
cut in half like a sandwich by the end
of the movie
when we saw those posters when Phantom
Menace was coming out we're like that's
the new Darth Vader by the end of the
movie we're like oh no that's the new
Wampa from Empire Strikes Back he's in
he's out
next up Riva the third sister
wonderful origin story wonderful story
Great Character Arc a lot of people
online like one after her because people
like I want Star Wars to be [ __ ]
white or whatever the [ __ ] but I thought
Moses did a phenomenal job more
importantly the character herself
poignant you know and terrifying and to
tie her origin in with Anakin Skywalker
literally killing her and she just
happened to live through it um
traumatizing to say the least so I
thought that character is a welcome
addition to the Star Wars lore
next up Ray
or Ray Skywalker as we found out at the
end of the the last JJ movie she took
that name she's like I'm gonna keep that
name going
great character some people online were
like how she know how to do all this
[ __ ] four [ __ ] she just found out bro
rewind watch Star Wars how does he know
how to do that [ __ ] four [ __ ] use the
force Luke God took down the Empire like
almost single-handedly and he didn't
know nothing just like Luke she too
doesn't know who her parents are her
story she don't have an Uncle Ben and an
amp root a razor and stuff she traded
and sold and and [ __ ] like that pretty
heartbreaking
next up kylo Ren
takes the I'm not understood as a
teenager Trope to like the highest
degree to a murderous uh degree Adam
Driver is an amazing actor so I'll watch
him do anything he's the son of of Leia
and Han and you know I ship that
relationship hard in the 80s so you know
I was happy to say oh the results of
that relationship in the books they had
kids as well but in the movies they got
this one kid and then that son of a
[ __ ] went and [ __ ] killed Han Solo
he killed one of my favorite people like
look you got issue everybody got issues
with their parents right we all got
complaints some more than others and
stuff from what I understand Han Solo
didn't do anything to this kid certainly
didn't do anything he could deserve be
killed by him [ __ ] so kylo Ren you go
[ __ ] yourself you robbed me in my
childhood
there it is my friends that's the Jedi's
and the Sith we're getting to today now
mind you there are many many more that
we didn't get to and I could hear all of
you out there on the internet right now
going you call yourself an expert what
about blank blank blank
unless it's a mainstream piece for
people who aren't as familiar with Star
Wars as you
in the comments how badly I did I've
been on the internet for 30 years so I'm
used to that sort of thing